vous savez si nous allons faire cette chose, nous
devons trouver un nom quelque chose je
sais quelque chose d'accrocheur quelque chose à laquelle
j'ai pensé électrique se sentir
comme
oh alors qu'en est-il des ordinateurs d'entreprise non
non jeux Star Trek je jure que je vais conduire
cette voiture juste à l'heure je vais bien nous allons
faire rouler la voiture juste à côté de Jésus
calmez-vous sérieusement d'accord rien de trekking
Jésus ne se sentait pas comme quelque chose que les
gens vont comprendre, vous savez que cela
doit être quelque chose que vous avez vu que
vous êtes  tout comme mec, je dois juste l'avoir des
pommes
excusez-moi
maintenant Apple comme le fruit le fruit de la
création Apple c'est simple c'est Fisk qui
fait écho avant Atari dans l'annuaire téléphonique
vision c'est tellement
mieux que les ordinateurs à faisceau de phaser